تنضمي لان من الاسكندريه مراسله صباح
العربيه نجاح حجازي يسعد صباحك يا ندى
عرفيني على زياد وسير عشقوا لشخصيات
الانمي تفضلي
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير يا سهام صباح الخير يا نادين
يعني الصوره تتكلم المره دي ههه صباح
الخير يا زياد
يعني عايزه اقول لك ان احنا الناحيه
الثانيه يعني الحاجه
الحاجه اللي همم الكاميرا مش مبينه لكم اه
لا هو ده دلوقتي مش زياد بس كميه الناس
اللي واقفه الناحيه الثانيه بتصورنا بسبب
زياد يعني كثير جدا والعربيات واقفه
وعاملين يعني ضجه في اسكندريه ههه زياد
انت وسط يعني نظرات الاعجاب والاستغراب
انت بتمشي ازاي في الشارع ههه
طب عايزه اعرف انت اصلا ليه بتعمل كده
يعني من الاول بقى ايه اللي خلاك تتجه
لموضوع انك تقلد شخصيات الانمي هو ده فن
ياباني يعني احنا عندنا فنون شبه الافلام
والمسرح هم عندهم برضو التاكسيد ده بس
الشخصيات مش موجوده في الحقيقه
اليتيم ان هو شبه التمثيل بس انت لازم
تجسدتي شخصيا ان شخصياتهم بتبقى مميزه لبس
مميز بشكل يعني تفاصيل لازم
تتجسد الاول وبعدين همم يعني بنمثل شبهك
بنعيش الشخصيه
عشان توصل للمرحله دي انك تاخذ الرزق تمشي
كده في الشارع يعني انا مستوى عالي ههه
ازاي ويعني المقاسات بتاعه الجسم وبس همم
كل الفرق بقى نقص القماش ونخيطه خلاص
ان هو مش ملابس بس يعني انت عندك كذا همم
عدسات وميك اب بالضبط الستايل بتاع الشعر
يعني انا اي شخصيه بناتيه لازم تبقى لبس
هو هو الشعر الوش كل حاجه يعني حتى
الملامح لو ملامح وبتبقى خشنه شويه باحاول
اللي هو اغير في شكلي بحيث ان انا اقرب له
اكتر معاكي يا نادين ايوه ندى احنا معكم
ومتابعين هذه المقابله مع زياد بس كمان
يعني ممكن بالمستقبل بنشوف اذا لقى له
عروسه كمان بتحب الانمي فبيكون بيعملوا
عيله مشروع مسلسل كرتوني متكامل ياباني
ايه رايك
ههه
نادين بتقول لك كانه وان شاء الله في يوم
من الايام ممكن تقابل عروسه تكون هي كمان
بتحب الهري بيبقى مشروع بقى مسلسلاني مش
كبير
بيجمع صحابه بيصمم لهم ملابس عشان ينزلوا
كلهم كجروب بقى همم يعملوا يجددوا شخصيات
مسلسل معين خاصه لو المسلسل ده ترند صح
يعني احنا قبل كده كنا نازلين كنا حوالي
ثمان شخصيات كانت هي يا جماعه مكونه من
ثمانيه واللي نفسهم واحد فالفكره اول ما
جاءت لي كلمت اصحابي اللي كانوا بيتفرجوا
على المسلسل ويعجبهم وفعلا ونزلنا وتمشينا
تقريبا
احتلنا اسكندريه كلها عادي
طب ردود افعال الناس بقى يعني بتبقى ايه
والله في ناس بتبقى عارفه المسلسل وعارفه
الشخصيات
بتبقى معجبه وتيجي تتصور معك طيب
يعني
مش عارفه
شو اكثر شخصيات الانمي الي حبها زياد شو
الشخصيه اللي بتخمصها هلا تحديدا
طيب يا زياد سهام بتسالك ايه اكثر شخصيات
الانمي اللي انت بتحبها هو الشخص اللي انت
دلوقت متقمسه دي تكلمنا عنها شويه دي
شخصيه اسمها جوجو دي يعتبر فعلا
بدون سبب
ثانيه من مسلسل
ويعني كان في زواج للشخصيه كان اسمه هاشيل
الحجر
فدي بقى اللي كانت عامله رعب شويه للناس
ان كل واحد كان شايف هو فاكر
كان عامله رعب شويه
لا بس تحب الانيمي جدا وواضح ان انت عندك
جمهور كبير جدا من الاطفال او المراهقين
ان هم اكثر ناس بتابع لانمي في مصر وانت
محقق ملايين المشاهدات على تيك توك
انت طبعا استغليت وقت كورونا علشان تبدا
ان انت تنتشر
الفكره في ان انا اعمل شخصيتك كنت بتفرج
زي اي حد
اما كنا قاعدين طبعا كل واحد حاسس بملل
انها بتفرج على المسلسل هو هو فكنت بشوف
شخصيات لبسها طبيعي يا شباب فدخلت في
الدولاب قعدت اقلب قلت طيب انا محتاج اخلي
الشعر يبقى هو هو طيب ما نجرب وفعلا اول
شخصيه جربتها اول ما نزلتها لقيت يعني في
باب كويس جدا انا نفسي ما كنتش متخيل
عجبني الموضوع قلت لا احنا نجرب
انت نورتنا يا زياد والله
للمشاهدين
انت اختك الصغيره واختك الكبيره كمان شكرا